you and I we should be open with the
audience be truthful always truthful
yeah yeah when I socialized we did
holidays we did there were two nights in
a row two nights in a row that's right I
had a tree trim party mm-hmm at my home
and very nice which is very nice and
then the next night you had a big party
and and and my you know I listen I love
Christmas I adored Christmas we always
have a big Christmas party and
celebrities come like yourself mm-hmm
traditionally Lindsay Lohan likes to
take the kids down to the basement and
teach them how to freebase Moreau
I mean it was nice you actually I know
what else does this
you had us trim the tree it was such it
was like Marty it was your home it was
your it was your Christmas special he
stood around I took it seriously
no one else was doing it Onan broke into
a German rendition of Oh Tom and bomb
yes it was like having the SS back it
was no it was quite amazing
yeah and then his party was amazing you
know and I is a cash bar that was
surprised yeah yeah
you gotta bug boy KFC can cater and the
strangest guest list I mean I had bigger
stars you had huge stars at your party I
had a lot of big stars but you had Mike
he had Rob Kardashian Octomom Octomom
was there yeah
Flo from the progressive insurance
[Applause]
she's what the kids not just kids when
they play the Peter Pan could you the
spies right away when I get stars to
come they come out yeah no no it was fun
it was fun any New Year's resolutions
for you are you gonna change anything
this year you know it's interesting that
you say that first question on your list
but I second I did make a little list of
new because I'm a big believer in your
resolutions I think there and and some
of them will I do them all I don't know
can we ever do what we hope we can
accomplish New Year's resolutions 2016
mm-hmm learn something new about my
assistant what's his name good be more
Kendall and way less Kylie that could be
any yeah I'm gonna take that one punch
anyone who's shortened this guacamole to
guac yeah
stop accidentally ordering Chinese food
in a Chinese accent yeah we've all done
it
stop trying on Underpants without buying
them yeah stop sexting during sex
finally tell Conan I'm his real father
oh stop speaking Spanish by simply
adding OH two words in English and stop
shamelessly promoting my autobiography I
must say my life is a humble comedy
legend now I'm paperback whatever fine
books are sold yeah hey thanks for
watching please subscribe to my youtube
channel so they will stop making me
shoot these videos